[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
right now I think there's a lot of
hero-worship around entrepreneurs and
there are a lot of stories in the press
that make it seem easy that make it just
seem like you could wear flip-flops and
a hoodie and walk around in Palo Alto
and poof you're an entrepreneur and in
fact those who that have built these
high scale businesses there is a ton of
blood sweat tears and years of time
involved there I decided to go out and
interview people the people behind
businesses to determine how they were
able to create and scale companies the
datasets the largest right now in the
United States on founders that go zero
to a hundred million in revenue with
five years of history not more than ten
years to go to scale and it's a data set
that looks across industries and across
geographies in the u.s. what I came back
with is an extremely accessible learn
about teachable code of six skills that
that basically mean that anyone can
create and scale a new idea and I think
that's really important to realize it's
a fundamental human ability to create
something
[Music]
you
one really important tool that's
available to every single person is to
ask questions if you want to spot
something you have to be curious and so
there's some research that shows that a
five-year-old will ask about a hundred
questions a day but as people age and as
we go through a traditional education
system and believe we're experts it's at
some point in time in our work in our
careers we ask less and less and less in
terms of questions about the world
around us so if you want to spot a gap
one thing you just have to be curious
you have to scratch the itch of
curiosity
Under Armor founder Kevin Plank is a
great example so he solves his own
problem he is known in the University of
Maryland where he played football as
Maryland's sweatiest player okay so he
was not a good athlete and he weighed
his cotton t-shirt under they was
wearing under his uniform
it weighed three pounds at the end of a
practice because it had so much water
weight and that was not a good thing for
Kevin so the gap he sees in the
marketplace is no one is making Under
Armour making better undershirts for
football players and he goes to a local
fabric store in College Park Maryland
he buys this stretchy bolt of fabric he
takes it to a local tailor $450 and
seven prototypes later he has his
original Under Armour synthetic shirt
and then the original product many
people don't know didn't work it was
worn under red uniforms and made all of
the football players pink because they
had a scavenger kind of fabric that was
making the color the dyes go on the
white undershirt so he tried again and
again
Kevin is really funny about saying you
have to solve your own problems and look
in places in his case that football
players wouldn't normally be looking to
you know armor up the big tough athlete
so you just have to look for gaps all
around you be alert ask questions and
solve problems and pretty soon you find
out that a lot of other people have a
similar problem in many cases
[Music]
there's some research around if you are
committed to a goal and you focus on
what's in front of you what's left to go
you're 2 to 3 times more likely to
complete that goal and so in the
entrepreneurial economy that's very
important if you instead think of the
ground you've covered to date thinking
you will slow down so this is some
important brain research cognitive focus
research that if you think what's ahead
of me your brain will throw focus
motivation and concentration towards
achieving that and this is about driving
for daylight always forward
Airbnb is a great example so those are
three founders Kevin Brian and Joe and
they continued to believe very much in
the idea that people would share their
homes the air bed-and-breakfast the air
bed that they had actually on the floor
of their own apartment that they hosted
other designers they are Rhode Island
School of Design hers originally and one
tech founder they did this experiment
for themselves to make their own rent
they had a note under their door that
said your rents up 25% in San Francisco
San Francisco is very expensive City and
they couldn't afford it and then there
was a conference at the same time in San
Francisco and other designers coming for
that conference they hosted three people
they believed very much this would
happen and no one else did this is a
very typical entrepreneurial story of
you know having everyone else past
because the idea is out on the fringe
it's out on the margin but if you are
driving for daylight you believe in the
horizon that you want to conquer and in
this case the Airbnb founder has
launched and relaunched and launched at
one point they went to South by
Southwest and launched as Twitter had
believing that they would have a Twitter
moment only three people used the
service and they were two of the three
as the founders so you know they kept
driving for daylight and built what is
now valued almost at a thirty billion in
valuation startup so it's one of the
world's great startup stories
[Music]
Buddha stands for observe orient decide
act this is a framework that came from
the US Air Force originally and very few
people realized that while the United
States has had supreme air power in the
world we have not had the best equipment
so the Russian MIG it could fly higher
and faster than an f15 or 16
EE 16 these are our fighter aircraft the
reason why US pilots could win in every
dogfight in a really tough competition
is that they would observe orient decide
and act faster move through the
transitions faster this is called
getting inside of an opponent's loop
learning loop so you learn faster you in
fact change the dynamics of a fight if
you have observed oriented made a
decision and taken an action a
competitor is responding to something
that a split-second before has been
changed so in the business world this is
every bit as dynamic and important of
force because if you can outmaneuver a
competitor even by a split-second and
make a decision and stay ahead you can
win in a very competitive globally
linked technology accelerated economy a
great example here is example PayPal and
many people know this example because
they had six different business models
in 18 months that is moving very rapidly
through decisions and decision cycles
Reed Hoffman who was there in the early
team basically they were getting a
lawsuit by Visa saying you are acting as
a credit card company and Reed went to
negotiate that on behalf of PayPal and
the larger credit card company would not
drop the lawsuit but instead Reed
convinced them to study the problem for
a year
okay never study a problem by the way
because while that large credit card
company was setting the problem the
PayPal team moved through
again multiple decisions they merge two
companies they ended up going public
selling to eBay the much more
interesting thing is that they go on
this founding team to start LinkedIn
YouTube Yelp slides Tesla Motors Digg
Yammer which recently sold to Microsoft
the first investment behind Facebook etc
etc so they go and seat the entire next
wave basically of the Internet
and when you spend time with that
original team and ask what is it how did
you do that what they will say is the
first thing is just not going to be it
you have to observe what works and what
doesn't and it's going to be
counterintuitive
[Music]
before you start a project you actually
want to build in some failure and think
of that as testing and think of that as
learning and think of that as pushing
the innovation edge on whatever you're
doing if you have a perfect record you
probably aren't building something the
world hasn't seen you already have a
roadmap you already know how to do it
the speed with which the world is
changing means that you can't have a
perfect record but you can be smart
about failing so the idea here is to
fail wisely and all failure is not the
same by the way if you fail wisely one
thing to do is set a ratio and say you
know one in three things I try won't
work and that's what I want
Jessica Heron is a great example she's
the co-founder of wedding channel comm
originally and now Stella and dot which
is a fabulous fast-growing online retail
company supporting women has a whole
workforce of direct sales with women
stylists and Jess will say one in three
things that she tries won't work and
that's what she wants
there's her ratio and what she wants the
stylists to tell her is very very
quickly love it or lose it love this
piece of jewelry love this handbag in
the inventory line move it at volume
lose it this doesn't work for whatever
reason it doesn't even matter just lose
it as quickly as possible and that's
called failing wisely the ability to
network minds is the ability to harness
the brainpower of other people and to
pull bright minds towards you to help
build solutions and this is really based
on the idea of cognitive diversity so we
the world right now we're talking a lot
about diversity that you can see on the
outside gender race socio-economic
differences my research is showing that
really what matters is what's inside
your mind to people who look very
different if they are trained exactly by
the same institutions in the same manner
can think the same so the idea here is
to tap into different points of view and
encourage the cognitive diversity in in
your work in your workplace to unlock
solutions
in order to take an MRI you have to be
inside the machine it's very
claustrophobic it's very loud and cold
you have to be there by yourself no one
can be with you you have to be
completely still and so for children
this is extremely difficult 80% of kids
have to be sedated to take an MRI scan
and that ups the medical cost and it
certainly ups the risk so for the
designer of this beautiful technology he
felt very much like a failure the most
vulnerable people children were not able
to handle the scan very well so his
response to this is very beautiful and
that he goes and networks minds and he
gets together a lot of the GE design
team and lab techs and doctors and
nurses and then many children and day
care providers and designers of
children's art museum exhibits that are
very large things that kids would
interact with and this ability to
network minds produces the adventure
series now for the GE MRI machine and
there are seven adventures the kids go
on so if you see this machine it's all
painted it has decals there's music
playing there's a story when the
children go to the hospital they meet a
camp counselor not a nurse that person
is all dressed up they're told a story
in one case that it's a pirate story it
will be loud they will have to be quiet
it will be cold all of these things make
it an adventure now for kids and that
largely comes from listening to children
in the networking mines in this case of
of the customer and we often discount
kids in in designing things or in the
business world we don't actually take
into account that point of view so in
it's an example of how GE has done an
amazing job at networking minds and now
the sedation rate in the adventure
series for kids seven different
adventures is nearly zero so it's the
Zac same technology a completely
different outcome
[Music]
gifting small goods is about the
exchange of small favors small
kindnesses something of value that you
can do for someone else for a colleague
and it's a five-minute favor so this is
the idea that you don't have to throw
yourself off of a train for someone else
you do however need to figure out little
ways that you can be helpful so a small
good would be forwarding a resume
writing a few lines of code critiquing a
proposal giving feedback you know
opening an opportunity for someone these
are five minute favors they're they're
not big heavy lift things to do and the
interesting part about the transparent
world and the speed of communication now
is that people will know about this this
used to be the right thing to help out a
colleague now it makes you a lot more
productive there's a real generosity and
kindred spirit among people who have
built things I believe because they know
how hard it is
[Music]
you